okay as predicted donald trump
was never going to be reinstated to the
white house in august
there is no mechanism for reinstatement
in the united states constitution or the
in the united states law uh one of the
biggest
um purveyors of these ideas was
trump sycophant mike lindell ceo and
founder of the my
pillow brand who will also be holding
some kind of what he's calling a
symposium on
in sometime in early august whether he
even knows what symposium means i don't
know
but he now has a new date on which he
says donald trump will be reinstated
mike lindell has set august 13
as the date where trump will again
become the president of the united
states
this is the first time he's put a
specific date
on this entire thing business insider
reports on it
and says my pillow ceo mike lindell
says he believed former president donald
trump would take the impossible step
of being reinstated as
president on august 13
speaking to brannon howes on the
conservative
wvw broadcast network on sunday
lindell said that by that date trump's
reinstatement
would be the talk of the world donald
trump won
he claimed i mean it's pretty simple
okay
let's take a look at the video in which
mike lindell
says this by the time august 3rd the
morning of
august 13th it'll be the talk of the
world going hurry up
let's get this election pulled down
that's right the right
let's get these communists out and you
know that they've taken over that
and you'll see when i say that you know
and tell people what's going to happen
to all the people that were involved i
don't know right now the biggest concern
is getting this election pulled down
donald trump won i mean that's pretty
simple
okay and there were many down ticket
senators do that they did too and stuff
you'll find all that off
by the time so in addition to this
degree of insanity uh mike lindell is
also claiming that
uh at his symposium in august he has
uh voting machines that he is going to
be holding some kind of a
mock election to reenact how the voting
machines
did all the stuff that he claims that
they supposedly did so
there's there's a few different things
going on here that are worth talking
about first of all
you know how many times has the date
changed at this point of course
it's never going to happen it's not
going to be august 13th a couple weeks
ago mike lindell also floated the idea
it might be september
it's never going to happen now a lot of
people come to me and they say
david uh sir um do you think
that mike lindell believes uh
this stuff do you think he actually
believes that donald trump
uh genuinely won the election
congratulations sir
you just won the election exactly and i
think the answer is it doesn't matter
um if i had to guess i think
that mike lindell has the sense that
there was some fraud he he believes
he doesn't really know whether it's
enough that it would have given the
election to donald trump
but he doesn't care and he's making a
bunch of money he's getting a ton of
publicity he has all of his conservative
friends promoting his pillows
you know everybody's got a coupon code
for his pillows and so on and so forth i
don't think it matters i think the
important thing is
that the big picture of this is a really
really dangerous grip
because of the fact that their followers
are so gullible
and if you think that those followers
will ever learn their lesson when august
13th comes and goes
and oh lo and behold donald trump does
not become president of the united
states
if you think then they will finally say
you know what guys this just isn't going
to happen it's over
look as an analogy at how many times
those evangelical
end of the world apocalypse types have
gotten their dates wrong for the rapture
we've interviewed some of them on the
show and every single time that they get
the date wrong
they go back to their followers and they
say there was a miscalculation
or some bad actor got in the way or
someone didn't pray hard enough or
whatever the case may be
and the exact same thing is what is
going to happen
here either it's the deep state that got
in the way even though it
certainly would have happened if they
didn't or whatever the case may be
that's all going to happen
um the question will be what is the
eventual grift going to be will it
transition into well
the next thing really now is just the
election and
it's time to just donate let's donate
and we'll we'll win 2022
and then it'll become 2024. like is that
the grift
is it that some of these people like
mike lindell might run for something in
some way there's been this idea that
mike lindell might run for governor of
minnesota
i don't know ultimately where the grift
is going to go but for now it's been
very profitable for mike lindell and
trump
whether he believes it or not there are
reports trump does believe it which is
just wacky i mean just cuckoo for coco
puffs but the reports that trump
believes it
um suggests to me that he also
is seeing this as a reason to
reinvigorate those rallies
that he's been doing and certainly trump
making no friends
with most of the people that were in his
administration and that's exactly what i
want to talk about
next do not forget that one of the best
ways to support the david pakman show is
by supporting our awesome sponsors and
today one of those sponsors is
sheath underwear the weather is warming
up
it's hotter it's stickier out there and
unfortunately for many of us that comes
with a lot of sticking and rubbing and
chafing
with traditional underwear that is what
sheath
underwear has solved sheath has
developed
unique boxer briefs with multiple
ergonomic
compartments in the front preventing
skin on skin contact that means
everything stays separate dry cool and
comfortable
with sheath underwear there is no more
sweating no more chafing
no more readjusting it's great sheath
underwear is giving the david pakman
show audience
20 off when you go to sheath
underwear.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
give sheath underwear a try
my experience has been great i believe
yours will be as well
you can find the link underneath this
video and do not forget to use that
promo code pacman
for 20 off